Want to know what's heating up in theathers this weekend?
- You are now the Amazing Captain Underpants!
[singing]
Two kids pull the ultimate prank on their principal in Captain Underpants.
Is it okay that I'm kind of loving this?
- I will set you free!
- It is our sacred duty to defend the World.
Wonder Woman stars Gal Gadot as the Amazon princess who must help save the world.
If you don't pass the exam, you must repeat the semester.
I'm this close to being kicked out of school.
In 3 Idiotas, three guys go on a search for their long-lost college buddy who disappeared on graduation day.
See what's hot in theaters with this week's fanticipation.
So, what's your weekend ticket going to be?
Let us know by commenting.
See you next time on weekend ticket.